This is part three
of the FOM lecture on
the introduction of
the head and neck. And
in this part, we're
gonna be covering all
12 cranial nerves.
And this will serve
as an introductory
summary and overview of
these cranial nerves,
which are vitally
important for the
function of not only the
head and neck, but
the rest of the body.
So the cranial nerves,
as I mentioned, there
are 12 of them and
they are numbered based
on the sequence in which
they leave the brain
cavity. So all of them
emerge from the brain
and they exit the brain
cavity in order to
innervate structures
outside of the skull.
So it starts
anteriorly from
olfactory nerve or
cranial nerve 1.
And then the larger
numbers, cranial nerve
11 and 12, for example,
the accessory and
hypoglossal nerves
emerge from the brain
and exit the brain
cavity more posteriorly.
so it is your
responsibility to know
how these cranial
nerves exit the brain
cavity and into the
structures within
and outside the
skull but we won't go
over this in detail
right now because
of interest of time
but make sure to
know their cranial
exits for the exams
a useful resource for
learning the functions
of different cranial
nerves is in the more
clinically oriented
anatomy ninth edition
which you have access
to to the electronic
copy through the NYIT
library and specifically
figure 10.4 which
is shown here shows
a nice diagram where
it highlights all the
different functionalities
of the cranial
nerves and as i mentioned
in the beginning
of this part of the
video or the lecture.
This is just an
introductory overview of
these 12 cranial nerves.
So I will be going
over just one or a couple
of the functions of
each of these nerves,
but make sure by the
end of the block,
you will need to know
all the functions of
all 12 cranial nerves.
So towards this goal,
I highly recommend
you to pause this video
to create this table
right here. And
what this table will
show is summarize basically
all the information
I will be giving
you, not only in this
part of the lecture,
but by other lectures
given by the anatomy
faculty members.
So in the first
column, you'll have the
cranial nerves numbered
as well as their names.
In the second column,
you can have the
cranial exits. So
these are the foramina
or the openings
that the cranial
nerves will use to
exit the brain cavity.
And then we also have
the fiber types. Are
they sensory, motor,
visceral, or skeletal?
And then their functions.
So what do they do?
So what we're going to
do now is we're going
to go through this
cranial nerve marathon.
And I'm going to make
it interactive so
you understand some
of the functions.
so the best way to
start is with cranial
nerve 1 which is also
called olfactory nerve
and tract and
the reason why we
differentiate between
olfactory nerve and tract
is the stock that you
see here coming out
of the brain is
referred to as olfactory
tract because technically
it's not a nerve
it's actually a
pinched portion of the
brain that extends
towards the nasal cavity
but the olfactory nerve
refers to the nerves
that connect the
olfactory bulb to the
sensors in the olfactory
epithelium which is
where you're actually
going to be smelling
the compounds so
olfactory nerve as the
name implies has only
one function and this
is olfaction or the sense
of smell and because
sense of smell is one
of the five special
senses that only
exist in the head and
neck, its fiber type
is special sensory. So
if you have a coffee,
a tea, or any kind of
food in front of you,
you can go ahead and
smell it. And you can
thank this cranial
nerve or the olfactory
nerve for allowing
you to smell wonderful
things in the world.
Now let's go over
to the optic nerve.
And similar to the
olfactory nerve, this
has only one special
function, which is
vision. And because
vision is one of those
five special senses,
the fiber types
is also going to be
special sensory. So
if you're looking at
these slides right
now, then you can
thank the optic nerve.
Moving forward, we
have the oculomotor
nerve, which is
cranial nerve three.
So if you see the
laser pointer right
now on the slide,
you can follow it
around the slides
while you keep your
head still. So just
move your eyes.
And if you're following
the laser pointer,
then it means that
you're using this
oculomotor nerve. So
oculomotor nerve is
responsible for providing
motor innervation to
extraocular muscles,
which surround the eyes.
And these include
the superior ******,
inferior ******, and
medial ****** muscles,
as well as inferior
oblique and levator
palpebrae superioris.
And this last muscle
is responsible for
elevating your eyelids.
And you'll notice that
I have a grayed out
text down here. So in
subsequent slides, if
you see these gray
texts, it means that
these are other functions
and the fiber types
that are included
in these cranial
nerves. But for now,
don't really focus
on them. For this
week, just focus on
learning at least
one or two of the
functions of each of
the cranial nerves.
Next up is the trochlear
nerve, cranial
nerve four.
And just like the
last slide with the
oculomotor nerve,
while keeping your
head still, follow
the laser pointer.
So look down and
then to the side.
And this is the
function of the superior
oblique muscle. So this
is another nerve that's
responsible for eye
movement or at least
one component of it.
And so it provides
somatic motor innervation
to the superior oblique
muscle. And the word
trochlear comes from
Greek word trochlea,
which means pulley.
So when you're dissecting
in the orbit region
in the anatomy lab,
you're able to see
the superior oblique
actually go through
this pulley system. And
that's why they have
a slightly strange
action on the eyeball.
Now, what I want
you to do is make
this face that
Albert Einstein
is making in this
famous photo.
And keep in mind what
you can see in this
photo, which part of
the face and the tongue.
And the sensory innervation
for what you saw
on Albert Einstein's
face, and hopefully
your face if you were
making one, is the
trigeminal nerve. So it
provides somatic sensory
innervation to most
of the head, as well
as the teeth. And it's
divided into three
major branches or
divisions, which you will
learn in both lab and
subsequent lectures.
So this means that if
someone touches your
face, hopefully you
don't get punched in
the face. But what
you're feeling, the
sensation, is thanks to
the trigeminal nerve.
cranial nerve six uh
so we're almost halfway
there is called abducens
nerve uh so just
like the trochlear
nerve it provides motor
innovation or somatic
motor innovation
to one of the extraocular
muscles that move
the eye and this is the
lateral ****** muscle
which abduxt the
eye so hold up your
skull or head still
and follow the laser
pointer and when you're
moving your eyes side
to side, you can thank
the abducens nerve.
Now we're on to
the facial nerve or
cranial nerve
seven. And so what I
would like you to
do is make a smile.
And facial nerve is
the cranial nerve
that allows you to make
facial expressions.
So they provide somatic
motor innervation
to muscles of facial
expression. And
there's a lot in
humans because facial
expression is such
an important part of
our daily lives,
including healthcare.
And you'll see that
it has a lot of
other functions,
which again, you
don't need to worry
about today, but
you will need to
know for the exams.
Cranial nerve eight is
called vestibulocochlear.
So what I'd like
you to do is,
well, if you're hearing
this lecture, it means
that you're using
the sense of hearing.
And if you want to
stand up and do some
jumping jacks and sway
your body left and
right, you should be
able to sense, you
know, where you are in
the space. And that's
because of the sense
of balance that you
have. And both hearing
and balance are
provided by this
vestibulocochlear nerve.
And both of these
senses are, of course,
two of the five
special senses of the
head and neck. So the
cranial nerve eight
or vestibulocochlear
nerve provides
special sensory nerves
or innervations.
Next up is
glossopharyngeal nerve or
cranial nerve 9. And
if you have food or
drink in front of
you, ingest them and
any taste that you
can sense towards the
back of the tongue
is thanks to the
glossopharyngeal
nerve. So they provide
special sensory or
the sense of taste
for a posterior one
third of the tongue.
Another function that
I'd like you to know
at this point for
glossopharyngeal nerve
is that they provide
visceral sensory
innervation to the
carotid sinus and body,
which talked about
earlier in this lecture.
Now we're on to the
vagus nerve or the
cranial nerve 10. This
is a big nerve and
it provides visceral
motor innervation.
So it's part of the
parasympathetic pathway
for all the smooth
muscles and glands in
the thoracic abdominal
visceral organs.
So vagus means wander
in Latin. So it
lives up to its
name. So its nerves
extends all the way
from the head, neck
into the thoracic
abdominal regions.
So one of the other
functions is actually
what you're hearing.
The ability for
me to speak is thanks
due to the vagus
nervous, specifically
the recurrent
laryngeal nerves,
which is a branch off
of the vagus, which
you would have seen
in block one anatomy
labs. So remember
that function as
well for this week.
Okay. So the penultimate
cranial nerve is
called spinal accessory
nerve or cranial
nerve 11. So this is
partly going to be
reviewed because this
is one of the first
nerves that you
studied in the anatomy
lab. So So you know
from before that
spinal accessory nerve
provides somatic motor
innervation through
the trapezius
muscle, but it
also innervates the
sternocleidomastory muscle,
the side of the neck.
So what that allows
you to do is to
rotate your head to
the left and the right.
So do that right
now. And that's all
thanks to the spinal
accessory nerve.
Now we're at the end.
So this is cranial
nerve 12 or the
hypoglossal nerve.
And this nerve
allows for tongue
movement. So let's
stick our tongues out.
And being able
to do that is
due to this
hypoglossal nerve.
So we've gone through
all 12 cranial nerves,
and it can be overwhelming.
But the earlier
you start studying
these cranial nerves,
the easier time you
will have with the rest
of the block on head
and neck in anatomy.
And because these 12
cranial nerves help to
unify the functions
of the head and neck.
So what's a great way
to organize all the
12 cranial nerves?
So this is one of the
ways which might be
helpful when you're
studying. So first, the
one grouping you can
have is to have cranial
nerves that only
provide special sensory
fibers and nothing
else. So these include
cranial nerve 1,
cranial nerve 2, and
cranial nerve 8. So
olfactory, optic, and
vestibulocochlear.
And these nerves
are associated with
special senses in
the head and neck.
the other way or the
other group that you
can create is cranial
nerves that provide
only somatic motor
fibers so these
include the nerves
that provide movement
in the eye so ocular
motor nerve, cochlear
nerve, and abducens
and also accessory
nerves and hypoglossal
nerves that provide
motor innervation
to the trapezius
sternocleidomastoid
as well as the tongue
and then finally we
have the third category
so these are
branchiomeric nerves you
don't need to know the
name but that means
they're derived from
pharyngeal arches which
we'll cover in the head
and neck embryology
lecture for what they
are but these nerves
so cranial nerve 5
7 9 and 10 these are
going to be relatively
complex nerves because
they're going to
provide a lot of
different functions. So
these will probably be
the hardest ones to
study for, but get
started on starting to
learn their functions.
So here's an example
exam question. So a
NYIT comm student
is about to get her
wisdom teeth pulled.
Which of the following
cranial nerves should
be targeted for
local anesthesia.
So think about what
provides sensory
innervation to the teeth.
So the answer is
pigeminal nerve or
cranial nerve
five, because that
division or branch
off of that will
provide sensory
innervation to all the
teeth, both upper
and lower rows.
So for the lecture on
introduction to the
head and neck, these
are some of the high
yield topics that
you should focus on
when you're studying.
So the first one is to
understand the
anatomical organization
of the skeletal, nervous,
vascular, digestive,
and respiratory
systems, and how these
changes from newborns
to adult for the
ones that I've shown
you in the lectures.
Also know the three
danger zones in the
head and neck and why
they're dangerous.
Also know the locations
and functions of
the organs that only
exist in the head and
the neck, including
glands and then know
the names fiber types
and functions and
the cranial exits for
each of the cranial
nerves and then finally
pay attention to
the clinical correlates
that i went over
in my lecture finally
extra set of tips
so head and neck is
definitely difficult
uh region to study
there's a lot packed
into a fairly small
space but don't panic
start one by one and
one way you can focus
on, you know, which
topics to study is to
go through the CPG
learning objectives.
And what you can also
do is start learning
the cranial nerves,
which is vitally
important for this
region. So this week,
I highly recommend
just getting
comfortable with the
names and the numbers of
each of the cranial
nerves. And then
next week, start
learning at least one of
the functions of of
each cranial nerve.
And then beyond that,
just keep learning
all the functions
that will be covered
in subsequent lectures
in more detail.
This is the end of
the FOM lecture on the
introduction to the
head and neck. I would
appreciate any feedback
you can give about
this lecture, which you
can do by opening the
PowerPoint presentation
file and clicking
on the hyperlink. And if
you have any questions
about the lecture
material, please contact
me using the email
address listed here.
Thank you for
listening and
hope you have a
wonderful day.